We're asked to graph this
function, finding the roots
and the vertex of
this parabola.
So to find the roots, when
people talk about roots,
they're talking about the points
of intersection of this
function and the x-axis.
So this is the x-axis here,
and this is the y-axis.
And you're going to intersect
the x-axis when
y is equal to 0.
So to find the roots, we said
y is equal to 0, so we solve
the equation, x squared plus
4x minus 12 is equal to 0.
All I did is I said y is equal
to 0, and I swapped the left-
and right-hand sides.
Now, to factor this, we have a 1
as a leading coefficient, so
we don't have to do the
all out grouping.
We can just think, are there two
numbers whose products are
negative 12, and if I
add them I get 4?
So let's think about it.
It looks like 2, positive 6, and
negative 2 would work, if
I go through all of negative
12's factors.
So this can be factored as x
plus 6, times x minus 2.
6 minus 2 is 4.
6 times negative 2 is negative
12, so that's going to be
equal to 0.
And if we have two numbers,
and if, when you multiply
them, they equal 0, that means
that either x plus 6 is equal
to 0, or x minus 2
is equal to 0.
Subtract 6 from both sides of
this equation, you get x is
equal to negative 6.
Add 2 to both sides of this
equation, and you get x is
equal to 2.
So y is equal to 0 when x is
equal to negative 6, or x is
equal to 2.
So let's graph both
of those points.
x is equal to negative 6,
y will be equal to 0.
So x is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So negative 6 comma 0.
That will be on the graph of
this function, or the graph of
this parabola.
And also the point,
x is equal to 2.
So 1, 2.
Just like that. x
is equal to 2.
So this is the point 2, 0.
Now to find the x value of the
vertex, there's actually
several ways of doing it.
There is a formula that
gives it to you.
But actually, the easiest way
to figure it out is it's
actually going to be the
midpoint between the two 0's.
If you already figured out the
0's, the x value where the
vertex was going to lie--
because the two 0's are always
symmetric around the axis of
symmetry, which is the same x
value as the vertex.
You can just find the midpoint
of these two points, and that
will be the x value
of the vertex.
So let's just do that.
So if we take the midpoint, we
can literally just average
these two numbers.
So negative 6 plus 2, over 2 is
negative 4 over 2, which is
equal to negative 2.
So the vertex is x is
And when x is equal to negative
2, what is y?
So x is the vertex, and then y
will be equal to negative 2
squared, is positive 4.
4 times negative 2
is negative 8.
And then we have a
minus 12 there.
So 4 minus 8 gets us to negative
4, minus another 12
is negative 16.
So the point negative
2, negative 16 is
going to be our vertex.
So let me graph that.
I think it's going to fall off
of this graph a little bit.
So negative 2, and then we're
going to go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16.
So it's going to be
right around here.
We went off the graph paper.
But negative 2 all the way
down to negative 16.
So that right there
is the vertex.
Negative 2, negative 16.
All the way down here.
We can even lower the y-axis.
And so if I were going to graph
the parabola, it would
look something like this.
It would look something
like that.
Just like that and obviously
it would keep going.
Now, I figured out the vertex
in this problem just by
averaging the x values
of the two routes.
That gave me the x value of the
axis of symmetry, which is
this right here. x is
equal to negative 2.
That's the axis around which
the parabola is symmetric.
The other way to figure out the
x value of the vertex, is
to use the formula, negative
b over 2a.
So the x value of the vertex
is equal to negative b--
negative 4-- over 2 times a.
a is 1, so over 2, which is also
going to give you x is
equal to negative 2.
Now, the last way to solve for
the vertex is to complete the
square on this parabola
right here.
So what we can do is
we can rewrite it.
We can say this is y is equal
to x squared plus 4x.
I'm going to put the
minus 12 out here.
And what we want to do is add
and subtract the same number,
so I can express this
as a perfect square.
So if I take 1/2 of 4x, or if I
take 1/2 of 4, I get 2 if I
square that.
I could add a 4 here, and
then subtract a 4.
And then what that does is it
turns this into x plus 2
squared, right? x plus 2
squared is x squared
plus 4x, plus 4.
We've seen that multiple
times.
So you have x plus 2 squared.
And then you have the minus
4 minus 12, minus 16.
So this is just another
way of writing
this exact same function.
But when you write it this way
you see that the lowest point,
this part of the function right
here is always positive.
It's a quantity squared.
The lowest value that
it can be is 0.
But then it can only
go up from 0.
So the lowest point, the lowest
y value we can take on,
is when this expression
right here is 0.
And when that happens, the
y value is negative 16.
Now, what x makes
this value 0?
Well, x equals negative
2 will make this 0.
If you wanted to say, x plus 2
is equal to 0, this expression
right here is going to be 0 when
x plus 2 is equal to 0.
Subtract 2 from both sides,
x is equal to negative 2.
So that's another way to find
the vertex, all of them
equally valid.